the european commission president has
called on the eu to ban oil imports from
russia as la fonda lyon addressed the
european parliament in strasbourg she
outlined a sixth package of sanctions
against moscow over its war on ukraine
and called for a phased embargo of
russian oil imports by the end of the
year
here's what the eu commission president
had to say
today we are addressing our dependency
on russian oil and let's be clear
it will not be easy
because some member states are strongly
dependent on russian oil but we simply
have to do it
so today we will propose
to ban all russian oil from europe
this will be
this will be a complete import ban on
all russian oil seaborn and pipeline
crude and
refined we will make sure that we phase
out russian oil in an orderly fashion
so in a way that allows us and our
partners to secure alternative supply
routes and at the same time be very
careful that we minimize the impact on
the global market
and this is why we will phase out
russian supply of crude oil within six
months
and refine products by the end of the
year
and let's cross straight over to
strasbourg now where dw correspondent
marina strauss is standing by marina a
promise there to phase out russian oil
but with a very long stretch ahead will
this be enough
yeah the commission president jose
lafondo line said it i will repeat it
because it's important she the eu plans
to or the eu commission proposes to
phase out crude oil within six months
and uh refined all by the end of the
year so it's a long traditional period
so some time for e member states to
prepare and what we're hearing from the
commission from eu officials is that two
eu countries will be given even more
time namely hungary and slovakia maybe
even a year or longer to phase out
russian oil because otherwise they would
probably not agree to this deal because
they're heavily reliant on russian oil
so is this efficient uh we we don't know
um there are very different opinions on
this matter of course the eu commission
says clearly yes we don't they don't
know how russia how vladimir putin will
react because he's clearly unpredictable
that's what the eu commission says but
what we're hearing from meps what many
of them said this morning is that
there's a fear that with because of the
ban of russia of russian oil in europe
prices could rise in europe and also all
over the world and that could mean that
russia could sell its oil to other
bidders to other countries for a very
high price and still make a lot of
revenues but that's one of the reasons
why the eu is not phased
it's not like ending russian oil
immediately but that's the reason that
ursula from the lion give cave for this
long transitional period
now fond du line also proposed some
other sanctions can you tell us more
about those
yes there are namely four or five other
points that she mentioned this morning
one of the most important points is
points is that
the largest russian bank the spare bank
will be de-swifted so taken off of this
international financial transaction a
tool also to other russian banks will be
targeted then also important
the eu commission proposes to target
military officials that were involved in
the atrocities in butcher and in mario
poll then um the eu commission wants to
ban
three more russian media that they blame
them for
spreading fake news and misinformation
we haven't got the names yet but are
still waiting for it and then they will
also target consultants uh russia like
european consultants that help advise
russian companies
all right marina knows briefly this is
only a proposal when will all this be
decided
it's the eu council so the eu member
states that will now have to decide and
with the last sanctioned packages it
always took um 48 hours a few days so
it's likely that it will be the same
amount of time again all right marina
thank you marina strauss in strasbourg